flotte enfin comme un air de vacances en
cette période où l'on a avant tout envie
de respirer le grand air
une bouffée de plaisir mais avant
quelques conseils
donc ce qui va être le plus difficile ça
va être de tourner à faible vitesse
c'est ça le plus difficile je te des
bris de moteur tu refais de petit tour
du parking donc l'attention
ça va partir un peu plus fort et c'est
parti pour 25 km sur des trottinettes
électriques tout terrain à la découverte
des chemins secrets
un souffle de liberté qui recrée le lien
avec les grands espaces
enfin on sort à mon mec f1 racing des
deux à loeb matthew dans laquelle la
chute de m
qui plus est
c'est abusé
[Musique]
très impressionnant je trouve que les
bus il faut bien faut bien maîtriser
c'est après la sensation l'impression
que c'est la continuité de nos pieds du
coup c'est vachement agréable très
agréable en s'évadant n'oublie un petit
peu la situation sanitaire ça fait du
bien on prend du plaisir c'est collé
aucun effort aucun bruit
le nez au vent et les yeux grand ouverts
entre plaines et coteaux village des
curiosités locales
c'est un peu l'objectif de des balades
qu'on propose c'est de montrer la
diversité et la variété des paysages en
touraine il y en a pour tout le monde
des bords de loire des vignes de la
forêt c'est très très une heure et demie
pendant laquelle confinement et
couvre-feu n'existe plus seule la
distance physique et de lise
seul le vent vous couvre le visage